und Abfahrt
ja heute habe ich in Köln zwei Stunden
auf meinen zugewartet und dann wurde mir
gesagt dass er ausfällt ja und da habe
ich mir gedacht komm gar kein Problem
gibst du der Bahn morgen noch mal eine
Chance nehme ich ein Hotel ja und dann
komme ich auch endlich mal dazu hier
diese ganzen Spielsteine zu verwerten
ist doch toll oder hier alles alles
gebaut
Bahnhof
ist das schön ich liebe die Bahn nämlich
wirklich ich habe seit 12 Jahren eine
Bahncard 100 ich war über 100 Tage im
Jahr Zug ich bin also kein Bahn Anfänger
der nach 35 Jahren das Auto einmal
stehen lässt und sich dann aufregt dass
die Wagenreihung nicht stimmt aber warum
wird die Bahn seit einigen Jahren immer
schlechter das ist nicht nur mein Gefühl
das sagt auch die Statistik die Bahn
hatte noch nie so schlechte
Pünktlichkeitswerte wie heute es ist
selten das ist bei einem Versagen die
eine Wurzel allen Übels gibt hier schon
sie heißt Privatisierung nicht alle aber
die meisten Probleme der Bahn sind
dadurch entstanden oder verschärft
worden
Privatisierung das war ja ein Zauberwort
der 90er fanden damals alle
oberaffentittengeil ja so die damals
geredet in den 90ern Boris Becker hatte
noch Geld und war Internet Pionier der
Kommunismus war zusammengebrochen und es
gab eine neue Show namens wetten dass
kann man sich heute alles gar nicht mehr
vorstellen alles ging alles war geil DJ
Bobo fand die Sprache für das was alle
tief in sich fühlten aber nicht
ausdrücken konnten Verse Party alle
haben sich gefragt können wir vielleicht
noch viel mehr von diesem geilen
Gewinner System haben mehr Kapitalismus
waren Privatisierung super dumme Idee ja
warum als staatliches Unternehmen waren
die Spielregeln der Bahn klar du bist
für alle da also willst du das möglichst
viele Menschen möglichst pünktlich an
ihr Ziel kommen es hat nicht immer
funktioniert aber das war zumindest das
Ziel eine AG hat nur ein Ziel möglichst
schnell möglichst viel Gewinn machen
deshalb hat die Bahn begonnen auch mit
anderen Sachen Geld zu verdienen bis
heute macht die Bahn die Hälfte des
Umsatzes mit Geschäften die nichts mit
dem Kerngeschäft zu tun haben sie hat
über 700 Beteiligungen und
Tochtergesellschaften darunter waren bis
vor kurzem sogar Buslinien in Serbien
und Schweden gut für Gewinne außerdem
natürlich Kosten senken und dann sind da
Menschen von der Unternehmensberatung
zur Bahn gekommen die hat letzte Woche
noch eine schraubenfirma optimiert und
jetzt war die Bahn dran und dann haben
sie sich die Bahn angesehen wie ein
Metzger die sind durch die Bilanzen
gegangen und haben sie angeguckt was
teuer ist
Personal oh I Menschen
super teuer also wurden 100.000 Stellen
abgebaut schien auch weg damit also
wurden in den letzten 30 Jahren über
5.000 km Schienennetz gestrichen ja habt
ihr richtig gehört in einer Zeit in der
man längst wusste Klimakrise heißt
möglichst viele Menschen müssen vom Auto
zum Zug wechseln in der Zeit haben sie
sich gedacht hey lass uns doch weniger
Strecken anbieten das wäre total gut
wenn die Leute vom Dorf einmal mit dem
Auto eine Stadt fahren in der sich die
Strecke für uns lohnt und dann haben die
mit ihren metzgeraugen weiter geguckt
was teuer ist und gesehen
weich oh das ist ja teuer oh da haben
wir so viel oder haben wir so viele von
ach mann was das kostet die haben
weichen abgebaut dass die Hälfte der
weichen entfernt wurde wird bis heute
dazu das Züge warten müssen 25% sind in
maroden Zustand Weichen sind wichtig
denn die bedeuten ein
kann einen anderen Zug überholen weniger
weichen das ist so als wenn man bei
Autobahn sagt hey die ganzen Auto waren
Spuren dieser super teuer lass uns doch
einfach alles einspurig machen also wir
preiswerter und dann haben die gesehen
wenn die Schienen und die Zügel jetzt
ständig gewartet werden nee das ist ja
auch unnötig teuer deswegen kommt man
heute kaum noch hinterher das
Schienennetz zu flicken alles was damit
zusammenhängt produziert massive
Verspätung denkt bei der nächsten
Signalstörung einfach an DJ Bobo und
diverse Party die Bahn war filetiert das
kaum noch was übrig geblieben ist und es
war klar das ist überhaupt nicht
nachhaltig wenn du alles was du besitzt
bei ebay kleinanzeigen verkaufst hast du
erstmal viel Geld und dann merkst du oh
so ein Kühlschrank ist auch noch was
Feines denn es ist doppelt so teuer wenn
dir alles weggammelt die Bahn wurde eine
Aktiengesellschaft die anfängt zu
gammeln die Bahn macht Verlust wird
jetzt manchmal gesagt und das kann man
überhaupt erst sagen wenn man die Bahn
mit den Maßstäben eines aktienkonzerns
misst der die Bahn nicht sein sollte
Straßen in Deutschland sind auch
staatliche Angelegenheit der beschwert
sich niemand drüber das wird meine
Neunzigern schon als Kind beigebracht
man zahlt Steuern damit der Staat z.B
Straßen bauen kann pro Jahr sind das 15
Milliarden Euro die wir alle dafür
ausgeben meckert niemand drüber wenn ich
alle Straßen in Deutschland in eine
deutschlandstraßen AG verwandelt dann
macht dieses Unternehmen auf einmal pro
Jahr 15 Milliarden Euro Verlust was für
ein schlechtes Unternehmen und wenn die
Bahn jetzt Gewinn machen würde was hieße
das eigentlich weil die ja zu 100% im
Staat gehört würden wir alle Geld
verdienen sozusagen aber womit mit den
von uns die die Bahn benutzen also alle
verdienen Geld mit den Idioten die so
blöd sind die Bahn zu nehmen das einzige
Ziel der Bahn sollte sein möglichst
viele möglichst schnell pünktlich zu
transportieren das hat selbst die Ampel
erkannt sie will laut ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag dafür sorgen dass
endlich mehr öffentliche Gelder in die
Schiene fließen als in die Straße an
alle die bei der Bahn Arbeiten ich weiß
auch dass ihr nicht für die meisten
Probleme verantwortlich seid und es gibt
bei euch auch tolle Leute die trotzdem
Teil der Lösungen sind und sagen ich
weiß nicht warum der Zug stehen
geblieben ist aber ich sage Ihnen jetzt
wie sie nach haben kommen und wenn nicht
kümmert meinen Kollegen vor Ort sich um
Taxi
und warum wollen Sie nach haben habe ich
schon erlebt aber es gibt auch Züge die
drei Minuten vor Abfahrt auf einmal
ausfallen völlig kommentarlos und dann
wäre es schon schön wenn jemand sagt
warum ist das so was sind
das ist keine Begründung es
verspäten wieso bezahle ich für eine
Reservierung extra wieso sehen die neuen
ICE aus wie in der Folge Black Mirror
habt ihr nicht gesehen könntet ihr im
Zug sehen wenn da ordentliches Internet
wäre und warum gibt es kein Podcast
Abteil in dem ich Podcast aufnehmen kann
ja okay ist ein sehe ich merke ich hier
ist ein einzelnes Interesse okay aber es
gibt ein paar Sachen die könnte man sehr
schnell beheben alles andere ist eine
Geldfrage woher soll das Geld kommen ja
jetzt schon mal zwei Ideen erstens
Dienstwagen Privileg abschaffen der
Staat subventioniert Dienstwagen mit 3
bis 5 Milliarden Euro im Jahr und es
gibt keine Steuern auf Kerosin immer
noch nicht kann man damit anfangen dann
können wir richtig geiles Bahnland
werden wird halt nur teuer also ist es
eben wenn man sich den Klimawandel gönnt
wusste schon DJ Bobo original Zeile aus
party the way that is the big big price
oh ja DJ Bobo unser Nostradamus
so Leute für uns vom ZDF habt ihr als
Publikum Platin Status auch hier bei
YouTube kommt ständig jemand vorbei und
sagt hier das so ein kleiner satireclip
sein und da wird pünktlich geliefert
immer wenn ihr auf Play drückt schiebt
irgendwo in meinem Zimmer eine
VHS-Kassette in den Player alles für
euch so und jetzt tut uns mal im
Gegenzug ein Gefallen und checkt online
ein das heißt hier abonnieren liken
Glock Kommentar wie zum Beispiel
oberaffentitten geil ja würde ich mich
freuen oder was entsprechende zeitgemäß
ihr findet was vielen Dank